[Music]
all right the toll these despicable
attacks are taking on Israeli families
it's unimaginable we still don't know
exactly how many of them are missing
joining me now in Israel Ohad harell
whose sister-in-law is still unaccounted
for and Rabbi ARA lightstone former
senior adviser to the US ambassador to
Israel Ohad let's start with you first
of all our our hearts go out to your
family uh uh the the the absolute
devastation of not knowing what's the
latest information you've received about
your
sister-in-law um the latest information
is actually was Saturday morning we woke
up at 6:30 in the morning with the
Bumble arms then after a few hours my
brother gave me a call saying that uh he
just received a message from his wife
Shona which
saying uh they shooting at us and I'm
hiding uh I pick him up and we drove to
the south of Israel it's an hour and a
half uh from here ER we we came very
early the roads were still open and we
went through all the settlements along
the border with
Gaza we didn't find her uh the sites
that we saw were crazy it's like
UHA
chaos uh war zone we drove the roads
with with fire all around us and and
burning uh from both
sides and we ask all the people we saw
that came back from this uh
chaotic music
festival nobody remember her nobody saw
her they were
all
traumatic we went to the hospitals we
went to police
stations and this is now after five days
of of
waiting that's
it uh Rabbi lightstone I these
stories unimaginable pain and that's
what Hamas wants they want that pain
they want to hear that pain but they
want to inflict that pain and there are
people and countries that are providing
some type of assistance to this barbaric
effort now qadar which is hosting some
of the top leadership uh with Hamas
allowing them to stay in their Resorts
and their Swanky uh Swanky destinations
what can you tell us about
that well I can tell you just for
context that this is the single worst
week for Jews since the Holocaust and
growing up with my step-grandfather as a
holocaust Survivor of aitz he used to
say that sing is believing unless you
see stuff like ashz you can't believe it
what Ohad is describing even people who
saw it I can't imagine that they believe
it and we who've seen these videos I
don't believe that we believe it
and within that context I think one has
to decide that there are only two sides
to this you are either on the side of
good or you're on the side of complete
and total evil and everybody needs to
make a decision which side that they're
on and the fact that there are the
leaders of this organization uh sitting
at you know the equivalent of a Four
Seasons uh is
Despicable now Ohad you I'm sure have
seen video footage of the overwhelming
majority of Americans in prayer uh
Christians and others in prayer for the
Israeli people um I've felt it I've seen
it I've witnessed it but there is an
element in a radical element inside of
Western Europe and the United States
many of them with ties to you know
countries that support terrorism that
are celebrating hamas's
Victory how do you respond to
that uh I don't know what to say
look uh
Wars um
it's between countries between
armies uh these are civilians we are
talking about children we are talking
about women we are talking about human
rights I mean come on it's not it's not
about war this is nothing send them back
I don't care about the people who who
support it or them I hope it's minority
this is why I I'm talking whoever want
to listen yeah this is why I'm here I
want the the the world to make a public
pressure so we can get the the we can
get the the kidna one
back well Rabbi the point here is like
nobody is uh pushing for American troops
on the ground I don't think that's what
people are are are hoping for not the
Israelis they they want to do this
themselves and obviously they're our
strong Ally uh but they want to get this
Mission done in their own way and their
own
timetable and with maximum efficiency
and obviously with with no undue
casualties to civilians they actually
try to prevent civilian casualties Hamas
does the
opposite hence the kidnappings and the
torture you're 100% correct Israel needs
to do this on their own uh Israel in in
the four years that I a chance to be one
of the Liaisons in between the United
States of America and Israel Israel has
always said they'll protect themselves
by themselves what they need now is
ammunition and full political support
and it's our job as our Ally to give
them all the weapons they need to do
their mission and all the political
support to give them the space to do so
why does Israel need to do this on its
own because it's a tough neighborhood
and they need to re established
deterrent so nobody will in their
wildest imaginations think about doing
anything like this ever ever again not
because America said so and not because
the Brits said so and not because Costa
Rica said so but because Israel will
protect themselves by themselves this is
the promise that was made after the
Holocaust with never again and it was
renewed this past Saturday never again
begins again now it's our job as America
to help them I will make one comment to
your previous mention it's not just in
uh the streets Rashida Talib was asked
by one of the fox reporters uh does she
condemn we're getting into that in a
moment but yeah believe me uh Rabbi
we're uh we're on that like seven on
eight we appreciate you uh we pray for
your sister-in-law Ohad uh that she's
returned safely and to all those
families who are waiting for good news
about the whereabouts of their loved
ones and Rabbi please stay safe hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else